welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
now artificial intelligence is it our
new best friend or worst enemy in Kuwait
AI Bots have started reading the news
which means journalists could be out of
a job including eurozana
I don't think so
I really really is that what's going to
replace US News readers and presenters
I'd like to see their moderate of brexit
debate but of course this is a more
serious topic that was an AI bot
speaking the words written by our
producer Kieran very smart they're
Kieran but it does raise this important
question is AI a threat to the jobs of
almost all of us everyone from doctors
to teachers could see themselves made
redundant by new technology that's
faster and more intelligent than the
average human
but will all of it result in this
dystopian future where we'll be slaves
to AI overlords or a more utopian World
freeing us from the shackles of nine to
five living free to pursue more
leisurely activities here to discuss all
of this AI skeptic and director of the
future of humanity Institute at Oxford
University Professor Nick Bostrom Nick
thank you ever so much for making time
to speak to us and you know I know we
can oversimplify this and talk about
sort of robots taking our jobs it seems
to be that's what the media most grasps
onto but give us a sense of the power of
AI if you could
well I think we are just at the early
stages of
what might become the biggest transition
in human history the arrival of the
machine intelligence era
um long ago we have sort of automated a
lot of human physical labor
um first through draft animals and then
with steam engines and so forth and now
we're starting to automate human
cognitive labor
how dangerous is that to replicate
cognitive behavior
well I've long argued that this
development of machine general
intelligence and as I think shortly
thereafter machine super intelligence
will be associated with significant
existential risks like threats to the
very survival of the human species
um all so however I think if we get it
right it presents tremendous
opportunities to to solve you know a
very wide range of different problems
that have plagued Humanity uh throughout
our history you have argued
argued and temp machines are a greater
threat than climate change at some point
you stick by that
yeah that's that's my assessment
um
I think
um both in terms of time scale
um there's a lot of uncertainty about
that but in the last several years
progress in AI has been
really quite impressive
um and also about the risks if and when
we do reach human equivalence and then
Super intelligence
it's just something completely
unprecedented we've never developed
super intelligences before and uh I
think we might only get one try on this
we need we need to get it right on the
first shot
um because once you have
unfriendly antagonistic
superintelligence it might not be
possible to sort of put that Genie back
into the bottle
um so we've got to get it right for at
the first try and it looks quite
challenging to do that just to make sure
that it's aligned and does what we
actually want to do I mean it does sound
terrifying this idea of super
intelligence I've seen it described as
god-like super intelligence and I
remember having beers with a friend a
few years ago and he was saying the
thing I'm most scared about super
computers and I thought he was off his
rocket this was probably about seven
years ago he was right back then how how
far along the curve are we and how fast
is the train going in terms of being
able to Reign it in if we need to
the trade is going really fast I mean
everybody have seen these recent
um large language models with chat GPT
for it seems like almost every other day
there is like a big new release
um the image generation models like
everything you see in this picture is
artificial right the virtual backdrop
actually generated by one of these uh
Dali 2 image generation models I'm not
even sure whether I'm real or artificial
um and it looks like
this current algorithms
generalize very well and scale so you
pour in more compute you pour in more
data and and they just seem to reach
higher levels of performance with as yet
no player end in sight
um there was an open letter being spread
around the technology in the AI
Community Elon Musk was one of the
signatories saying we need to pause the
development of AI in order to assess
some of these risks you can see that we
can call on all AI developers to stop
this immediately pause for at least six
months he's asking for the training of
AI systems more powerful than gpt4 I
believe that Bill Gates was actually not
one of the signatories of those and he
has made the case that we do need to
keep the development of AI up in the
west because otherwise we're going to
fall out of the race when it comes to
competing with China and obviously there
could be risks involved with that
yeah right now the the Western
particularly certain large Western tech
companies I think have a lead uh
things are quite competitive in this
space
um also in terms of building the
computer hardware
um that is needed to run these large AI
models the key producers of that are in
the United States in Taiwan and in South
Korea
um and recent export regulations have
tried to style me the sales of AI chips
into China so that might make it harder
for Chinese developers to to keep up
with The Cutting Edge I think ultimately
machine super intelligence should be
developed I I do think during the key
parts of the transition though it would
be wise to be able to do it carefully
and not to have a sort of hyper
competitive situation where there are 20
different companies that are each viring
to get their first and the whoever
decides to make some extra precautions
or to check their systems like carefully
just immediately falls behind and the
race is won by whoever is willing to
take most risks I think that would be a
bad situation so having some ability to
coordinate uh maybe to slow down for a
few months I think that could be a
positive yeah ideally you'd want it to
happen in concert but of course in the
real world companies compete in
countries compete and this idea of
having one of the most consequential
technological impacts on Earth as you as
you sort of laid out at the beginning of
our conversation just how severe it
could be and all these decisions being
made by a small handful of tech
companies private companies don't
regular people deserve a say in this
yeah I think the development of of
machine superintelligence is really an
issue not just for one company or even
one country it's an issue for for all of
humanity we we are all in this boat
together like if it goes badly we're all
doomed and if it goes well I think we
should all uh you know have a slice uh
of The Upside as well and so I think
this conversation will need to and I
think it will broaden out policy makers
are getting a lot more interested I
think people as they start to get
first-hand experience using these
systems and seeing how they get better
so quickly I think that that will focus
a lot of attention on this over the
coming months and uh years I I I think
you're right in saying that everyone's
sort of experimenting now a lot of
people know what chat GPT is they're
starting to see the power of this
hopefully will find a way for us not all
to be doomed Nick Bostrom director of
the future of humanity Institute thanks
so much for joining us this evening
thank you